[Musique]
octobre 1989 43 femmes à travers le
monde donnait naissance à un enfant
aucune de ces femmes n'étaient tombées
enceintes auparavant combien puis-je
vous en offrir
j'ai adopté
six de ces êtres prodigieux
doté de capacités
présente la toute première place de le
bret l' académie l'un d'entre vous soit
il prendre la parole c'était un monstre
c'est tout contrat samitier dingue ça
n'a rien du vent
[Musique]
c'est ma jupe que tu portes sous mérite
de se voir ailleurs et plus partis c'est
qu'au lieu de voir que rien n'a changé
quand j'ai sauté que je me suis retrouvé
coincé dans le futur tu sais ce que j'ai
trouvé
rien du tout c'est prévu pour quand
exactement
dans huit jours t'es chiant il y à une
personne qui va m'empêcher de sauver le
monde
il faudrait que l'académie soit au grand
complet
bingo
anoh frangine à nouveau schéma
oui
lève toi on y va tous à sauver le monde
on se trouve là